the word Consciousness is just highly
ambiguous so you seem to just assume
that humanik Consciousness is
consciousness and I don't really care if
people want to reserve the word
Consciousness for that then we just need
some some other word for the sort of
ambient awareness and everything in the
universe right so there's lengthy
debates among academics on like okay do
we say a particle is conscious or do we
say it's protoc conscious right so then
you can say okay we have
protoconsciousness versus Consciousness
or we have like raw Consciousness versus
reflexive Consciousness or humanlike
Consciousness and arguing about which
words to associate with different
flavors and levels of experience uh is
you're just kind of kind of running
around in circles the full podcast is
out with yosa Bach and Ben goril
subscribe to get
notified